VACCINATED.
DANA?
>> BE INTERESTING TO FOLLOW
THAT.
THANK YOU.
>>> THERE ARE NEW CALLS FOR
INDIA'S PRIME MINISTER TO
IMPLEMENT A NATIONWIDE SHUTDOWN
THIS MORNING AS COVID SPREADS AT
A BREAKNECK SPEED.
MORE THAN 4,000 PEOPLE DIED FROM
COVID-19 ON FRIDAY MARKING A NEW
SINGLE-DAY HIGH.
THE SCRAMBLE TO VACCINATE
RESIDENTS AND STAVE OFF THE
STAGGERING RATE OF INFECTIONS IS
BEING FURTHER COMPOUNDED BY THE
NEED TO FIND OXYGEN.
IT REMAINS IN SHORT SUPPLY AS
TANKS OF IT ARE FLOWN IN FROM
THE U.S. AND AROUND THE WORLD.
CHRIS LIVESAY HAS MORE FROM NEW
DELHI.
>> Reporter: LIKE A WILDFIRE,
COVID IS CLAIMING LIVES FASTER
THAN INDIA CAN BURY OR CREMATE
THEM.
THIS AFTER IT.
LIKE THE COUNTRY HAD DODGED A
FREIGHT TRAIN.
LAST YEAR AS THE U.S. AND MUCH
OF THE WORLD WERE REELING IN THE
PANDEMIC, INDIA WAS RELATIVELY
UNSCATHED.
TAKING CREDIT WAS PRIME MINISTER
MODI SAYING WE SAVED MANKIND
FROM A BIG DISASTER BY SAVING
OUR CITIZENS FROM THE PANDEMIC.
DEFYING WARNINGS FROM THE
GOVERNMENT'S ONLY SCIENTISTS,
THE COUNTRY OPENED UP.
SOCIAL DISTANCING VANISHED AT
POLITICAL RALLIES AND RELIGIOUS
GATHERINGS INCLUDING ONE ON THE
RIVER GANGES, THOUGHT TO BE THE
BIGGEST SUPERSPREADER EVENT IN
HISTORY.
THEN INFECTIONS SPIKED.
200,000, 300,000, AND NOW MORE
THAN 400,000 CASES IN A SINGLE
DAY FOR THE THIRD DAY IN A ROW
FORCING MAKESHIFT CREMATORYIES
LIKE THIS IN A NEW DELHI PARKING
LOT WHERE SOME ARE LAID TO REST.
HOW MANY PEOPLE IN YOUR FAMILY
HAVE COVID?
>> AT THIS POINT IN TIME,
PINCLUDING MY MOTHER, THERE WER
FIVE.
NOW THERE ARE FOUR LEFT.
>> THE SECOND WAVE IS NOT
SURPRISING.
>> Reporter: PRINCETON
EPIDEMIOLOGIST --
>> IT CAME BACK WITH AN ABSOLUTE
PHILOSOPHY THAT'S OVERTAKEN THE
HEALTH SYSTEM EVERYWHERE.
EVERY DEATH IS JUST A TRAGEDY
BECAUSE THEY WERE ALL AVOIDABLE
DEATHS FOR THE MOST PART.
>> Reporter: NOW THE COUNTRY IS
SCRAMBLING TO PROVIDE VACCINES
AND TREATMENT IN SHORT SUPPLY.
IT'S LINES LIKE THESE THAT ARE
DEFINING INDIA'S STRUGGLE FOR
SURVIVAL.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN WAITING
FOR OXYGEN FOR HOURS.
SEVERAL STATES HAVE ANNOUNCED
STRICTER LOCKDOWNS AS THE
GOVERNMENT FACES MOUNTING
PRESSURE TO RESTRICT MOVEMENTS
NATIONWIDE.
EXACTLY HOW YOU DO THAT IN A
COUNTRY OF 1.4 BILLION PEOPLE,
MANY LIVING CHEEK BY JOWL AND
HAND TO MOUTH BELOW THE POVERTY
LINE IS ANYBODY'